you can drink and drive cause a head-on
collision only do three years
major who shoved her friend off a 60
foot high bridge will spend as much time
in jail as her friends spend in the
hospital attorneys thought they'd worked
out a plea deal to keep the young woman
out of jail but the judge had another
idea
punishment for the teen who pushed her
friend off a bridge nineteen-year-old
Taylor Smith was in tears as she was
escorted away in handcuffs after being
sentenced to two days in jail you crying
for two days
that was funny I'm sorry sorry it's
dramatic it's very
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry bro I'm sorry
the wave of emotions I've had in this 20
seconds clip
is crazy I'm sorry bro first
I watched the clip of her game pushed
off a bridge
then I found out that they were gonna
make sure that this girl doesn't go to
jail and then I found out the judge said
[ __ ] that
she going to jail now so I got happy and
then I found out
it's for two days with
why is this news
bruh when I go to Montreal hospital I
spend more time in the waiting room
two days two days in jail [ __ ] two days
oh okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
is she crying
miss you soft Jordan I'm gonna push you
this is the moment Taylor pushed Jordan
holgerson off the bridge in Washington
state last August ready
[Music]
belly flopped to the fullest my guy
Jordan plunged 60 feet into the water
landing chest first she suffered six
broken ribs and punctured lungs at the
sentencing Taylor said she was sorry I'd
like to sincerely apologize to Jordan
Horizon family and friends for the pain
and humiliation I have caused by my
mindless action that occurred last
summer then off she went to jail for two
days Jordan says she's ready to move on
I think it's probably just as emotional
for her as me happy it's over
Taylor Smith was also ordered to spend
38 days on a work crew two days six
broken ribs and puncture lungs two days
bruh
yeah yeah [ __ ] are pushing
people off cliffs [ __ ] them up and
they get in two days bro [ __ ] being
caught with a bag of weed going to jail
for months
[ __ ] is you talking about
ribs and [ __ ] I don't even care if it's
my kid
uh you need to pay for that one that's
crazy ass [ __ ] and if that's my kid you
push up
this is the US I'm probably if I'm the
parent I'm probably getting sued for the
for the for for the for the the
the medical bills and [ __ ] like that
yeah you you [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're gonna spend two days because
them two days are not gonna you're not
gonna you're gonna be able to travel and
[ __ ] like that and whatever so whatever
yeah you're gonna spend you're gonna
spend two days
you're spending two days you're you're
spending two days listen there's nothing
much I got to say but but there's
there's no one but I mean it could be me
we're in the Frank Murphy Hall of
Justice in Detroit Michigan
the descendancing of 25 year old Amanda
Casal there's a lot of things that you
can do and your life doesn't have to be
over because of a poor choice you just
have to accept responsibility for and
find a way to make something positive
out of a very negative situation
basically what's going on is that this
is
um a court case in which
um the defendant was
caught basically under the influence and
she ended up crashing into somebody and
killed him right and also severely
injuring the fiance of the man that she
killed and they have five kids so that's
how it starts to go to court she's been
found guilty she's being sentenced to
three years in jail and then at one
point
um the the defendant her mom's boyfriend
starts laughing snickering so the judge
tells them get the [ __ ] out this
courtroom and then as he leaves his the
mom of the defendant also makes a
comment or says something funny so she
said you can leave too and on the way
off she said something a little extra so
she's getting held some contort she got
held in contempt of court so that's what
happened casan has been found guilty of
driving Under the Influence causing a
head-on collision that killed 31 year
old Jerome zerker and severely injured
his fiancee 31 year old Brittany Johnson
Amanda
[Music]
look what you did to my life
you ruined everything I had like my
Dad's life
I don't know who he is but whoever can
sit here at a tragic Moment Like This
and laugh and smile when somebody has
lost a family member I mean the entire
time that Mr zerkers
sister was speaking that clown and
that's what I'm going to call him a
clown was sitting there smiling and
laughing that you could go too because
if you don't know how to act you can go
to John so leave
anybody that can sit there and laugh
when somebody take her she's going to
bed
anybody else want to go you can go too
this is a court of law and these are
very serious matters and I understand
you all are upset because your loved one
is going to prison but guess what she's
going to prison for the choices that she
made these people are here grieving
sadding because the senseless act took
away their loved one and you all are
sitting around here like it's a joke
not according 502 not today and not any
other day ma'am you are being taken into
custody for criminal consent you're
disrupting the disrespectful Behavior
disrupted today's proceedings and you
ma'am are going to the Wayne County jail
for 93 days for direct criminal consent
anybody else want to go try it
try it oh my mouth will say to your
mouth back to 93 days you can drink and
drive cause a head-on collision on you
three years
well it depends where
in the states is going to be very much
more serious than Quebec so in the
States you know three years
and she's a female
I'm gonna say this go ahead
if you choose to drink and drive you get
no sympathy to me oh I put you on the
whole manslaughter list I don't give a
[ __ ] if you choose to operate a
motorized vehicle and be that
irresponsible you take someone's life yo
they could put you in for 25. I don't
care
you can't be a grown-ass person to not
do something that [ __ ] irresponsible
that kills other people on a regular
basis this ain't the 90s where we didn't
have awareness programs for this this is
today we hear about it all the time I've
been hearing it since I was a kid before
I ever even got in a car I'd unknown
and you kill somebody three years that
have families five kids
I've just seen so many [ __ ] go their
way to jail for like shitty ass drug
crimes and they got minimum minimum
sentencing of like and then you see this
[ __ ] and it's like three years and thank
God she's not in quebeco she would have
got like three weeks the mom laughing
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] who raised
you who the [ __ ] raised you
so the mom tearfully
um she spent the Thursday night in jail
and then tearfully apologized on Friday
morning I deeply apologize for what I
did I was under a lot of stress on a
gravel to the judge literally
sympathetic and counter sentence about
92 days and Saturday
so she held her in contempt once she
started apologizing and realized what
was wrong which you know the apologies
just be like I'm sorry I got caught and
I'm being punished I don't want to be
punished anymore so let me just admit it
uh and so she lit her up excellent now
I'm of this mindset courtrooms are not
for you to go around and [ __ ] around in
those are special places with special
procedures right you go in there they
tell you what it is beforehand you want
to go in there and [ __ ] around guess
what you might find out now you might
feel like whoa this judge is power
tripping these people lost somebody that
was very close to them and you came in a
courtroom it's one thing if you do it at
a funeral so one thing if you're doing
it in public courtrooms are not the
place for that there is rules for
contempt everybody as an adult should
know this you want to go around [ __ ]
around you might go to jail you might
find out
[ __ ] around and find out absolutely
you're not gonna get no sympathy for me
oh no no I mean your daughter did a
piece of [ __ ] thing and killed
somebody's and you laughing at that
family's pain chest or no stress if you
start a field giggle get the [ __ ] out
get the [ __ ] out and actually fake it
make it look like it steers to some [ __ ]
but but but don't yeah don't sit in
front of them no you can go [ __ ] you
can go I don't care if she would have
tripled your sense I don't give a [ __ ] a
go you could go some of y'all crazy with
the way I behaving
somebody here lost a love when you out
here laughing in their faces in your
courtroom in front of the judge being
disrespectful if the judge tells you to
leave peacefully you still making
comments on the way out and your
boyfriend trash too and he was the first
one to go
to jail stupid you [ __ ] up
I guess that kind of just [ __ ]
stupidity runs in your family what's
wrong with you
if my child did something that's
shameful you think I'm going in court in
front of the people who lost that person
understanding they're feeling the same
kind of pain that I'm gonna feel but to
a much higher degree because she's only
going to jail for three years he never
coming back
foreign
the kids too and you know what's so
[ __ ] up about this whole thing even
though you're being held in contempt and
you're going to jail I guarantee you if
that black family could switch places
with this white family and just have
their child go to jail for three years
they would switch in a heartbeat so
while you're over there being heartless
and laughing at her understand how crazy
that is how much lacking in sympathy you
have to have
Shameless throw the book of this [ __ ]
send her to jail forever anyways this is
what I thought I know justice system is
an interesting thing to watch unfold but
yeah let us know what you guys think